bella thorne is a bikini babe who loves  burgers very serious for knows the  famous and loved star took to social  media to x' day to document her daily  adventures  here's Bella posing in a white seashell  two-piece on snapchat showing off her  bare butt with a massive hamburger in  hand my snapchat is just really the most  man  um and I'm always posting on I'm always  doing weird it's like if you swatch my  snapchat you literally you're like one  of my friends really but the most  interesting thing about this post her  location  the actress appeared to be hanging in  Scott Disick's backyard she also shared  this pic of her gal pal soaking up the  Sun in what looks like Scott's pool at  his la mansion what happened was Scott  Disick we're chill we're chilling my  friends we're cool um I literally just  saw him so yeah like it's all chill  you